يوما بعد يوم تزداد عزله ايران الدوليه
بطورطها في حرب اوكرانيا تسعى طهران
للاستفاده من مد موسكو بالمسيرات غير ان
اكياس قالت صراحه ان عواقب دعم تهران
للحرب على اكياف ستكون اكبر بكثير من
فوائد تعاونها مع موسكو رئيس الوزراء
الاوكراني دينيس شمايل شدد على ضروره
محاسبه ايران على تورطها في الازمه
الاوكرانيه وتواطئها في جرائم حرب روسيا
اما المتحدث باسمي وزاره الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه اوليك نيكوليكو اكد ان بلاده
هو خلال اجتماعها مع الجانب الايراني قدمت
ادله كافيه على امداد روسيا باسلحه
ايرانيه وقال نيكولينغو لدينا مئات
الوقائع المسجله عن قصف في اراضي اوكرانيه
شرقا وجنوبا بواسطه طائرات مسيرات ايرانيه
كل هذه التصريحات يبدو انها لم تجد اذان
صاغيه حتى من قبل موجودين في ذلك الاجتماع
بمن فيهم الجانب الايراني الذي انكر كل
ذلك لان وزير الدفاع الايراني محمد رضا
الشياني نفى نفي نقاتي عن ان اوكرانيا
قدمت اي برهان
ولبريطانيا رايه يتفق مع اوكرانيا حيث وصف
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جينز بليفرلي
صفقات ايران وروسيا بانها دنيئه وتهدد
الامن العالمي وقال اننا سنحاسب التحالف
اليائس لايران وروسيا فالهجوم الروسيه على
المدن والمدنيين الابرياء لن يمر بلا رد
خاصه وان طهران باتت اكبر الداعمين
العسكريين وبعد عقبات اوروبا اعلنت
بريطانيا فرده قيود على اثني عشر قائدا
عسكريا روسيا متورطين في ضربات صاروخيه
استهدفت مدن اوكرانيا وكذلك على رجال
اعمال ايرانيين متورطين في انتاج وتوريدي
طائرات مسيره عسكريه استخدم ت في الهجره